ces jeunes blaireaux ont de grandes
chances de survivre à l'été la justice
vient de suspendre l'autorisation de les
chasser dans le Loiret et l'Eure-et-Loir
jusqu'en septembre
c'est une victoire enfin j'allais dire
parce que depuis le temps que on essaie
de
d'attaquer les arrêtés réguliers qui
sont pris contre le blaireau et qui font
que souvent même si le jugement est en
notre faveur la période est passée donc
la destruction continue les familles de
blaireaux ont trois mois de répit avant
la reprise de la vénerie sous terre les
chasseurs défendent cette pratique de
prélèvement jugés cruel par les
associations de défense de la cause
animale
et les plus handicapés dans tout ça
c'est le monde agricoles blaireau fait
du dégât les nous opposants disent que
c'est pas vrai mais si le blaireau fait
du dégât après il peut provoquer des
fameuses collisions sur les routes donc
si on doit attendre maintenant d'avoir
trop de blaireaux pour faire des choses
il y a des préfets qui autorisent les
tirs par les lieutenants par rapport à
des pièges donc laissons la chasse du
blaireau ouverte dès le 15 mai le
département les fédérations de chasse se
veulent des gestionnaires de la
population des espèces et c'est
justement le rôle que les associations
attribuent au blaireau au sein des
écosystèmes il a sa place dans la chaîne
alimentaire parce que il est prédateur
d'un certain nombre d'animaux qui eux
sont aussi indésirables pour l'homme par
exemple les limaces les escargots
certaines larves de d'animaux qui
pourraient pululer donc il a sa place il
est il a peu de prédateurs mais c'est un
bon prédateur lui-même les tribunaux
administratifs ont tranché en faveur du
blaireau pour cette année dans 14
départements